we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to davidp
you can call anytime i got a very
interesting voicemail from the eggman
explaining a conversation he recently
had with someone take a listen to this
this is interesting hey dave i just had
a business transaction with a
conservative republican in western new
york some guy i met i sold him something
in my house right so anyway we're making
this deal and i told him i'm a
registered republican but i hate trump
and didn't vote for him by the way
that's true did you know i am a
registered republican anyway i told the
guy this and now that he thinks i'm a
republican he gave me the inside dirt
like he's talking to his own team and i
said he is so fearful that trump is
going to run in 2024 and if trump runs
they're going to lose and they need to
find somebody better than trump because
biden is sick and harris is horrible and
they're going to get nobody in the dump
side but whoever they get is going to
beat trump so they need to replace trump
this guy was a terrified republican
conservative he thinks the world is
falling is caving in and he thinks uh
radical left wings are taking over
everything so um
they're scared dave and it was neat to
hear this guy talk to me like i was on
his own side it was really really
eye-opening and interesting yeah i mean
i think what the the thing to think
about here is
um it's there there's no exciting person
on the democratic side right now i mean
you know let's be honest joe biden
running for reelection isn't exciting
and i don't know if he will win
uh joe biden not running and it being
kamala harris is not exciting and i
don't know that she will win there's not
really excitement and you guys know that
i just in in general i'm not super
impressed with politicians anyway uh
they're just people at the end of the
day but there's no one that's exciting
me on the democratic side on the
republican side you have the deep
devoted trump cultists who still are
completely on his side but you also have
what the eggman is describing here
people who
believe trump's time has come and gone
and that trump will run again due to
narcissism and lose
and they don't know who to point to
either and i think this is why ron
desantis's name keeps coming up he's
competent in the sense of being able to
keep it together
he is trumpian in a lot of his ideology
and maybe
more dangerously effective at being able
to get a lot of that stuff done but it
is interesting that other than desantis
the people that the names you hear
mentioned by the right like more
traditional republicans i don't think
they have a chance i think the
republican electorate has moved beyond
sort of a traditional republican at this
point in time and that's why you say
well if it's got to be trumpian
but less whacked and maybe younger
that's why the desantis possibility
keeps coming up so we're going to wait
and see on today's bonus show we will
talk about joe biden's federal
contractor vaccine mandate being blocked
by a judge
we will talk about the legalization of
suicide pods in switzerland and we will
also talk about the bill backed by
progressives in congress for a four day
work week
what is the chance that this passes all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpacman.com